Victoria you are incredible and I was so
honored you danced to my song I'm so
inspired but you love Taylor happy
birthday thank you
what a way to celebrate your birthday
with a beautiful dance it was a pretty
epic birthday and a little message from
Taylor Swift for me come on like that
was really cool really cool I don't even
think cool is a cool enough word
I mean he's got a lot of big celebrity
friends and he's like a big slurry but
you've never got a note from Taylor
Swift no I never got a cake from her
either it was awesome I I was for her
that means Taylor sold me to Lynn felt
like you wouldn't get enough of the
robot you know the classic rumble steps
in there to be honest Val I wouldn't
have not never do rumba but times have
changed it's like Len versus Val round
372 no I I hope that's not the
reputation I have I loved Len I love his
feedback I'm like yeah but you know I I
think it's I try to engage in some
playful banter that he took way too
seriously and times do change you know
and I'm entitled to an interpretation
based on the song based on the rhythm
based on her based on what feels good
for her and us and I made the choices
that I made and he's allowed to disagree
with them Len looks really cute angry
and I appreciate it okay is there one
dancer is there anything that I don't
know that you're nervous about coming up
I think it's all difficult it all is
incredibly nerve-racking I mean I I
can't feel my legs and I still don't
know what they're capable of and I'm
very grateful that Val has continued to
show me what they're capable of and I've
spent the last year and a half looking
down at my feet and for the first time
I'm looking up a Sal and we're dancing
and so it's pretty crazy
[Music]
you